We know we can plug any number for x into an exponential function, like 10 to
the x. So that means that the domain of f is negative infinity to infinity or
all the real numbers. This also, then, is the range of g. We know that no
matter what number we plug in for x, in 10 to the x, this function cannot reach
0, and also can't drop below 0. So the range of f, goes from 0 to infinity,
none inclusive. This is also the domain of g. This brings up something really
important to know about logs. The input to a log must be greater than 0. It is
not possible to find the log of a negative number. This is a super important
point and we definitely need to keep it in mind as we keep working with logs in
the future.